i i don't actually think humans are
anywhere near uh the uh uh
optimal intelligence bound if there is
such a thing uh so i think for
humans or in general in general i think
it's quite likely you know that there is
an
a hard limit to how intelligent
uh any system can be but at the same
time i don't think humans are anywhere
near that limit
yeah last time i think we talked i think
you had this idea that uh
we're only as intelligent as the
problems we face
sort of uh yes we are upper bounded by
the problem so
in a way yes we are we are bounded by on
our environments
and we are bounded by the problems we
try to solve
yeah yeah what do you make of neuralink
and
uh outsourcing some of the
brain power like brain computer
interfaces do you think we can expand
our augment our intelligence
i am fairly skeptical
of neural interfaces because they are
trying to fix one specific bottleneck
in in human machine cognition which is
the bandwidth bottleneck input and
output of information
in the brain and my perception
of the problem is that bandwidth is not
at this time a bottleneck at all
meaning that we already have sensors
that enable us to
to take in far more information than
what we can
actually process well to push back on
that a little bit
uh to sort of play dell's advocate a
little bit is if you look at the
internet wikipedia let's say wikipedia
i would say that humans after the event
of wikipedia
are much more intelligent yes
i think that's a good one but that's
also not but that's about
um externalizing our intelligence
via information processing systems
excellent reflection processing systems
which is very different from
uh brain computer interfaces right but
the question is
whether if we have direct access if our
brain has direct access
to wikipedia without going already has
direct access to wikipedia it's
it's on your phone and you have your
hands and your eyes
and your ears and so on uh to access
that information and the speed at which
you can access it
is bottlenecked by the customer i think
it's already closed
fairly close to optimal which is why
speed reading for instance
does not work yeah the faster you read
the less you understand
but maybe it's because it uses the eyes
so maybe um
so i don't believe so i think you know
the brain is very slow
um it typically operates you know the
fastest
things that happen in the brain at the
level of 50 milliseconds
uh forming a conscious thought can
potentially take entire seconds
right and you can already read pretty
fast so i think the speed at which you
can
uh take information in and
even the speed at which you can add with
information can only be
very incrementally improved maybe i
think
if you're a very fast typer if you're a
very trained typer
the speed at which you can express your
thoughts is already a speed
uh at which you can form your thoughts
right so that's kind of an idea that
the that there are fundamental
bottlenecks to the human mind but it's
possible that the
everything we have in the human mind is
just to be able to survive in the
environment
and there's a lot more to expand
maybe you know you said this the speed
of the thought
so yeah i i think uh augmenting human
intelligence
is a very valid and very powerful
revenue right and that's what computers
are about in fact that's what you know
all of culture
and civilization is about they are uh
culture
is uh externalized cognition and we rely
on culture to think
constantly yeah yeah i mean that's
that's another
yeah that's not just not just computers
not just phones and the internet i mean
all of culture like language for
instance is a form of external
exclamation books are obviously
externalized cognition yeah that's great
and you you can scale
uh that externalized cognition you know
far beyond the capability
of the human brain and you could see you
know civ
civilization itself is um
it has capabilities that are far beyond
any individual brain
and we'll keep scaling it because it's
not rebound by individual brains
it's a different kind of system yeah and
and that system includes non-human
non-humans first of all includes all the
other biological systems which are
probably contributing to the overall
intelligence of the organism
and then yeah computers are part of it
non-human systems probably not
contributing much but
ais are definitely contributing to that
like google search for instance
big part of it
yeah yeah a huge part
a part we can probably introspect like
how the world has changed in the past 20
years
it's probably very difficult for us to
be able to understand
until of course whoever created the
simulation we're in is
probably doing metrics measuring the
progress
there was probably a big spike in
performance
they're enjoying they're enjoying this
you